vous habitez avec votre fille en ce
moment c'est bien ça dans mon
appartement
j'ignore quelle complète contre moi le
père six nominations aux oscars dont
celle du meilleur film réalisé par un
français florian zeller qui suis-je
exactement florian zeller ses débuts
remontent aux années 2000 n'ont pas dans
le cinéma mais dans le théâtre et la
littérature
il a 25 ans quand sa première pièce se
joue en 2004 elle s'appelle les autres
qui nous voulons vivre ensemble pour
toujours
ne jamais vivre pour vivre ensemble à
jamais ne jamais vivre jaoui et ce sera
comme mourir oui et il fera froid un
mari un amant une femme à ce trio
classique du vaudeville à la française
florian zeller ajoute sa patte
d'inspiration anglo-saxonne n'est pas
une pièce à l'italienne c'est une
question blesse j'ai toujours une
distance c'est dire on ne sait jamais
très bien où on est où à peine ont fait
un pas dans une direction on croit que
c'est un drame que tout de suite on
essaie dé rire pour tirer les choses
vers la comédie et dans cette
oscillation permanente justement on
arrive à créer une distance qui me
semble la seule possibilité pour parler
des choses qui peuvent être graves et
qui font sourire puisqu'elle sont graves
la recette de florian zeller c'est de
l'humour et de la mélancolie ses
inspirations
oscar wilde louis malle arthur rimbaud
quand il écrit c'est souvent pour un
comédien et ce comédien acceptent
souvent c'est catherine frot veuves dans
si tu mourrais en 2006 et toujours eu
tellement peur m'abandonne c'est
toujours été comme ça depuis que je suis
petit
claire arditi dans la vérité qui comme
son nom l'indiqué parle d'un menteur
maladif
j'en avais tellement dire comme ça du
jour au lendemain
j'aurai pour qu'un couple sur la terre
où robert hirsch père en perte de
mémoire tantôt cruels drôles tendres
dans le père dans ce qui était ingénieur
qu'est-ce que tu en sais s'apitoie
toujours ça veut dire de voir un vieux
monsieur qui dit adieu au monde enfin
finalement c'est sa sortie en 2012
le père est un succès à londres à paris
à vienne à stockholm à broadway
huit ans plus tard l'auteur adapte sa
pièce au cinéma
en angleterre c'est son premier film en
coup de maître qui le place sous les
projecteurs des oscars désormais florian
zeller adapte une autre pièce le fils le
rôle d' yvan attal sera repris par hugh
jackman à la fiche
[Musique]